avec la tragédie vient la force mais ta
foi notre seigneur
il ya dix ans aujourd'hui
on perdait un de nos frères le père de
joe
aujourd'hui nous honorons sa mémoire
giovanni n'oublie pas d'allumer un
cierge pour ton père et n'oublie pas le
gâteau
audio il est où ton cousin ouais il est
où les rangs des agents du fbi ont posé
des questions sur les os tu leur as unis
j'espère non je répèterai à personne ce
que tu as dit à propos du fbi surtout
pas ton oncle angelo
tu vois les deux gars au bar oui je
crois que je les ai entendu parler des
eaux les eaux les audio
j'ai fait ce que tu as demandé jeter a
mené à léo alors il est où
il va y avoir bien des révélations que
tu n'aimeras pas ou ne comprendra pas
mais tu le feras avec le temps elle
[Musique]
ça fait dix ans qu'on commémore la
mémoire de ton père la même date et il
est où les eaux
il a affaire aux fédéraux ça peut
devenir compliqué
[Musique]
si tu as quelque chose à nous dire je te
promets que ton oncle ne se fâchera pas
[Musique]
le sang coule dans nos veines
ce soir le sang doit être versée
il est temps pour toi tu apprendre la
vérité
tu es plus obligé de donner tout ce mal
ne le fait pas pour eux je le fais pour
ton père
[Musique]